[موسيقى]
هل يمكن ان نقول ان القضيه الفلسطينيه
قد تكون تحولت بعد ما حدث في الربيع
العربي بين قوسين مره اخرى الى مجرد شعار
يعني اصبح الاهتمام بالقضايا الداخليه
العربيه اهم الاهتمام بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
شعب حي
عايش موجود على الارض
ولن يقطع عليه ولن يقضى عليه
[موسيقى]
اليمين الاسرائيلي
والحكومه الاسرائيليه
واتجاهات في اسرائيل متصوره انه استمرار
قتل الفلسطينيين سوف يصبح بانسانيا
وقانونيا وسياسيا وتاريخيا وسوف نقتلهم ثم
نقتلهم ثم نضربهم ثم نضربهم
[موسيقى]
لمره
انا مره كان فيه كونجرس مان في
الكونجرس الامريكي وانا وزير خارجيه
وقال لنا في شرم الشيخ في احد المؤتمرات
وجاء ذكر القضيه الفلسطينيه
بيقول لي
نحن نضربهم ده
امريكي يهودي امريكي يهودي نحن نطربهم
ونضربهم ولا يسلمون
كان معي السفير حسام زكي كان 2009
بسنت كده قلت له ولا حاجه
افرضوا عليهم الاستسلام ما انتم خليتوا
اليابان تستسلم وخليته المانيا لهتلاريه
النازيه تستسلم
بس استطيع ان انا اؤكد لك
انه
هذا الشعب لن يستسلم قط وبالتالي انا مؤمن
بان الشعب الفلسطيني موجود
طيب مش عاوزين تدولو حقه في الدوله
خلاص
ننتظركم لغايه عام 2050 النهارده
ننتظركم ايه 27 سنه كمان ننتظركم 27 سنه
كده ننتظركوا 37 سنه كمان
لما عدد الفلسطينيين في المنطقه من نهر
الاردن
للبحر الابيض المتوسط يعني الضفه الغربيه
وعرب
اسرائيل او فلسطين بنسميهم الفلسطينيين
اللي هم مقيمين في دوله اسرائيل من 48
يكون عددهم 2050
مليون
وعدد اليهود
ثمانيه مليون
تسعه مليون
فرجونا بقى ما يتحدث به العالم الغربي من
مفاهيم
بيطبقوها على نفسهم وبيكذبوا بها على بقيه
البشريه كلمه ايه القيم
القيم الغربيه تفرض اننا نتصدى ضد هذا وضد
ذاك طب فرجونا بقى قيم الديمقراطيه هتقود
الى ايه في وقتها
وبالتالي هتبقى يا اما دوله
يا اما دوله يحكمها رئيس وزراء
من اصل فلسطيني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]